Thank you for the cheek swab information. I stopped taking my SEAC T capsules a couple weeks ago,
getting kidney pain when taking it. Do you suggest that I start with the T that you have instead of
the capsules? If I recommended the T, then yes, if I didn't recommend the T, then no, I wouldn't. But
if I did recommend the T that I would say, yes, I'm not. The SEAC T is a blend of herbs. So there are
SEAC T capsules. You can get those herbs in a capsule, too. But I think one of the key benefits of
the T was the fact that it was a T and you were sipping it, well, you're supposed to sip it for a
half an hour. That's the proper way to take SEAC T. On a fairly empty stomach, you make
put the T in a cup, add hot water and you sip it like a T for half an hour.
No, I'm not sure that, you know, it makes that big of a difference. But certainly,
that's why we have most of you doing the shake because I think there is a benefit
in the absorption rate in taking it that way. So it's not across the board with everything. So
don't quote me completely on that, but that is the way that you're supposed to be taking SEAC. So I
try to, we don't carry the capsules for that reason, we only carry the liquid.
Also, we had our point with the oncologist today and shared with him that we are going to discontinue
the medication. He took it very well, but had to add that some hearty cells deliver resistance to
therapy. And if I have to go back on treatment, it may not work. Is this a scare? Well, you know,
you could say that literally about anything. Well, if you have to go back on treatment, it may not
work. Well, if you stay on this, it may not work either. So I mean, there's no way he doesn't have
a crystal ball to know what's right for you. You have to, in order why? So, you know, you have to
pray about what you want to do and you feel you do what you feel like what God is leading you to do
and don't let anybody scare you either way. Don't let a natural doctor scare you that, you know,
taking this stuff is just going to kill you. That's why I just think that's so immoral. You know,
either way, you're doing that. You see the fear tactics I just think is immoral.
Also said, we can't go by tumor markers. Well, I would agree that you don't go by
anything specifically. You go by a lot of things. So you remember, we've said over and over that you
don't judge your progression or regression of your cancer based upon, you know, one test or even
two tests or even any objective tests. You have to guide it with, you know, again, with prayer and
which way God is leading you. And you know, you factor in, you're called to use wisdom. So you do
factor in what do my blood work look like? What do my pet skin look like? What is my, you know, any
other scans that I'm doing and how am I feeling? And then you make that decision based upon, you know,
factoring those all out, taking it to God and prayer. So I'll soon do you suggest to have markers
and other blood work drawn. Well, you know, doing blood markers and blood work is not, you know, real
expensive. So we have some people doing every month. So some people do every other month. So whatever
you feel comfortable with. So it's, it's got to be how you feel comfortable. But in a, you know,
just try to take, you know, the conventional wisdom that's out there, I'd say every 30 to 60 days
make sense to me. If I was in a greater state of remission, I'd go longer. But, you know, you're
talking to somebody who hasn't had their blood work done or any tests done for a while over a year. So
you know, should I? Who you ask? You're asking me? No, I'm not going to. I don't need to. I'm doing fine.
So I don't rely on those objective things. Is that foolishness? Well, it depends on who you ask. So
but it's my body and I have to answer to God with those decisions. So but I'm telling that's
telling you that's what you should do. So